as you're going through it and you're
talking about it
and you said my way of doing treatment
was what i was told to do and i realized
i don't know if this is the solution on
treating things it sounded like at one
phase
you were almost frustrated which
influenced you to want to do a little
more research
when i get a friend and i'll say you
know pat i'm going through really
challenging times i'm depressed all this
stuff i'll say listen have you sat down
and talked to somebody no
go see a therapist or go see a
psychiatrist or somebody okay
go uh recommend to somebody and they go
to them
and it's as if psychologists nowadays
their number one thing they do is what
here's zoloft here's prozac here's this
take this right
or you tell somebody i can't sleep at
night i'm having such a hard time
sleeping
and they go see a sleep doctor right and
you know say hey you need to take
laura's up
you need to take this pill to help you
go to sleep at night it's immediate
medication
question for you becomes the following
is the way
doctors are treating patients in all
different worlds
is it is it is it is it the way it is
today because of
lack of advancement is it the way it is
today because
the the method is kind of like well this
is how we've always done it this is how
you treat them just do this
so they're not willing to change a lot
and entertain new ways
or is a part of it because there is
the big sponsors of universities are
possibly bigger pharma that there's
money in this thing as well to make sure
that the
pills are being sold because that's a
form of money being made and these
things are very profitable
which one of those things is what makes
you think i mean this is your world
i'm just curious and i'm being skeptical
because that's the way i am is it lack
of advancement
is it we just don't want to change this
is how we've been doing and take our
order and give this treatment because
this is what works
or is it big pharma behind closed doors
doesn't want these treatments to stop
because it's pretty profitable
unfortunately i think the answer
is the last one i think it's very
profitable
so there's a ton of ways
that doctors are influenced
to prescribe more medications
even when it's marginally useful and
you know if you ever speak to a doctor
everything is very familiar so
you know you see these they you have
these drug wraps which will come in and
they'll take you to dinner right
fancy dinner and they're not supposed to
there's actually guidelines on this
but they'll take you to the fanciest
place
ever right and they'll treat you to a
nice
dinner and whatever and they get this
all the time so
that's one way they influence you they
do these talks for example and this is
all through medical school
and it happens that you know i could go
to dinner at a fancy restaurant
literally five times a week if i wanted
to all for free
like literally like 200
meals i would i could do that free i
just sign up like they'll do it no
problem
so the the thing is that they
they they they influence you in very
subtle ways and of course
for the big pharma these are not by
accident
they know what gives them a return on
their investments
and they know because they actually
track every single prescription that i
write
so i will write a prescription and i'll
send it to the pharmacy
and they buy information from the
pharmacy uh
and do it for everything so every single
prescription that i write
they know so when i go to some free drug
dinner i actually don't go to any of
these but
i used to like 15 years ago so if i went
to some free drug dinner where i got
some free thing
and they were uh promoting some blood
pressure pill
they could see that immediately my
prescription rate
of that blood pressure pill compared to
another one which was probably cheaper
and equally as effective yep went up
and that's that that's why they keep
doing this
and they keep inviting people out
then the problem is that level of
corruption moves all the way up
so then the next thing they do is they
you have
you get offered a role as a paid speaker
so
what they'll do is they'll give me a
opportunity
to give a talk for for other doctors and
they'll pay me
and again i don't do this but i could do
this if i wanted to
pay me fifteen hundred dollars for a
couple hours to enjoy a nice dinner
and and just talk to some other uh you
know
non-specialist about a drug and it
wasn't any random talk
they would give you the slide deck so
they're like
this is what you're gonna say and
unfortunately a lot of people
do that it's easy money it's a free
dinner like two hundred dollars is
fifteen hundred dollars
and you get to feel like a big shot
because you're talking to other doctors
teaching other doctors
then you get up to the uh the professors
and
the people in the university they're not
talking a few hundred bucks here and
there
they're raking it in from big pharma so
the big pharma companies are sponsoring
them
they get these people to do studies
where they get millions of dollars
and they get to do these things where
they go to like conferences
as part of the study and it'll be like
essentially a free trip
to like vienna okay with dinner with
your plane with your hotel and
because you're going to give a talk so
now you're not talking about a few
thousand dollars they're getting
stuff worth tens of thousands of dollars
they're getting sponsorship
for their studies which is tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands of
dollars
and of course they will advance because
the pharma company knows that this
doctor is very pliable to all this sort
of
bribery which is really what it is it's
basically bribery
so a doctor who advances doesn't advance
necessarily because he's very smart
but because he has a lot of people
pushing him in the background
with this money because if you're
bringing money to the university
university loves that right they're
always cash strapped so then
all the people who are taking the most
money from the pharma companies
get pushed up to the top and then you
have things like these trials
you know the things that we depend on to
make decision
they're all run by the pharmaceutical
companies right so it's like if
you know this so let's take the
antidepressants as an example
so you know that antidepressants you
have to
produce a study that showed that it
works in order for the fda to approve
the drug
which is fine that's the way science is
but
a drug company they underwrite all the
studies
so the thing is that they get to choose
which studies they publish in which they
don't so their strategy
is to do say 40 studies
and 20 of them they'll just throw in the
trash
and then they'll publish the other 20
well which do you think those 20
are the 20 that look the best yeah that
makes
and they've done it they've gone through
somebody has gone through and sort of
told the whole story of this and so it's
it's fairly well known
but if it's sort of like if you flip it
you know a coin
heads tails heads tails and you throw
out all the tails you say see
i get heads every time this is a great
drug so if you
throw out all the trials that don't work
then simply count the ones that do work
well all of a sudden your drug looks
great and this is the
exactly the story with antidepressants
so the drug looks great
and now you can go spend money promoting
it to doctors and say look look at the
evidence
the evidence says that this drug is
amazing
right but then you get out there and
says this drug doesn't barely even work
and that's the big problem so the the
certain money goes all the way up i i i
there's one study uh and the meg the
journal articles that publish these
studies they get a lot of money from
pharmaceuticals
if you ever read studies there's a huge
list of conflicts of interest
so for example in the sugar industry
what they found for example
is that you know they took all the
studies on sugar
and they divided that into you know the
people that got money from the sugar
industry
and virtually every study that the
people who didn't get any money from the
sugar industry found that
sugar is not good for you but there's a
huge number of researchers who got money
from the sugar industry
who are like yes it's sugar's not that
bad for you
so you know it's it's so like it's
so corrupt the whole thing is so corrupt
like you can't even imagine it's like i
look at it and i think
how can people allow this like how can
this be legal
it's it's insane that this stuff is
allowable
but the problem is that when when you
allow this sort of stuff now you get a
bias point of view
now you get all this information that's
being funneled down into the regular
doctors on the front lines
we're getting this information from the
universities not knowing that the whole
system is corrupt sort of top to bottom
and then you know doing because they're
generally good people most of my
a lot of friends of mine are doctors and
they're good people but if the
information they're
being fed is that oh antidepressants are
the greatest the greatest the greatest
the greatest
these drugs are the greatest greatest
greatest greatest then
what are you going to think your friends
say that the specialists say that the
university says that so you say here's
the drug here's a drug here's a drug
and it should never have been like that
it's the same for type 2 diabetes where
people just say give the drug give the
drug to the drug
it's like well what about the diet like
who's
talking about the diet who's talking
about how to lose weight because it's
not the doctors you can bet your life on
that
because there's no money behind that